[Music]
Ian can't handle it news submitted by
the Mandalorian yasya trailer no I
deserve this man is the new Star Wars
show they were putting on Disney plus I
heard bill Burson in the toy man
Tycho ITT is involved with it right I
believe so and Jon Favreau and Gus from
Breaking Bad oh he's one of the main
characters whoa how do they keep waiting
like this dude base bed they said hey I
heard the show like the first season was
over a hundred million dollars Jesus
[Music]
petitioners are trying to get the
world's scariest haunted house shut down
[ __ ] yeah I'm for it where do I sign
wait is this the titties one what where
they can touch your titties and stuff
whoa yeah I think this is that one where
they haunt you and you just feel
something that's hot so you say you're
supposed to be they're supposed to know
to [ __ ] with you however however they
want to show you what a dope job like
this really just grabbing a girl's tip
like that in passing it turns you guys
on no I mean it's it's free it's free
and you get paid to grab a boob but I
think when it's in passing like like is
it I don't think you understand the male
mind I know that's why I'm asking
questions yes it depends like how if she
looks good or not you know to true titty
is a titty and it's soft yeah ya wanna
grab me give me an answer
you said if she's hot it's good if she's
not so it doesn't matter you just kind
of want to grab you can I want to hold
it yeah come on correctly
I know it's just cities you see the
titty and you look at that yeah like
them looking good as extra credit if
they're hot it's better but if not each
don't grabbing an ass you can I wanna
grab to you yeah but if they're a but if
they're like a 50 year old lunch lady
it's it's very it's a motherly titty I
like I'll grab the titty but I'm not
loving this
exactly it's kind of like it's still
soft mm-hmm but I'm not horny and then
the girls were like the spirit you can't
stick your hand up the skirt if you can
oh yeah I'm saying
anyway let's take a hammer later go like
that y'all know this is just male talker
like that's why they even created a role
you know engineer they go don't grab a
girl's bra strap cuz this is all guys
are they just seeping they just they
just gotta hate it you just gotta do it
it's just I'm not just part of biology
yeah it's like you know like you see a
pimp on you to puppet yeah they're just
like a thing that you got to grab and
pop and yeah you see a boob you wanna go
like this but you seen if we want to
pinch yeah it's like what do you see a
mushroom you want to kick it yeah the
same [ __ ] I don't keep mushrooms well
you also don't grab pity so I can't
really talk to other guys mine will see
someone with a string hanging out their
clothes what you want to I never do that
cuz it's gonna ruin the [ __ ] shirt
sweater whatever is hanging on it if you
saw just a dick go by would you try to
jerk it off okay that's what we think
about you guys yeah but when you see
that the guys mugs that are about to pop
up don't you go we do the opposite we
pick up the shirt to help them out hmm
we're talking about nothing to do with
cities where did you reel the
conversation to well I'm trying to get
on track here so this place is called
McCamey Manor uh hunted boobs and so
this this place has got a very
interesting reputation where they used
to be in San Diego of another in
Tennessee and it's this horror house
they moved the whole house what I
understand about this place is the guy
who created it
his name is Russ courses the gosh she
names Ross yeah so he is like XML attire
or something and apparently it seems
like he was involved in like the
torturing part of the military and so
here are the cords nobody's asked aunt
arrogation not tortured I know that's
true if that is the proper interrogation
but it is to it but so this guy pretty
much figured out a way this is like the
conspiracy part of it that he figured
out a way how to legally torture people
and get his kicks cuz he's a sadist so I
was just aware people
sign up yeah you voluntarily sign up for
this you don't pay money and that's the
legal loop or it's like well he's not
you're not some transaction exactly
they're signing up to get [ __ ] up no
[ __ ] yeah but it's this point let me
explain to you what the [ __ ] up means
because it's pretty [ __ ] up so they're
saying that like in the waiver it says
like you know you are agreeing that you
might get your nail bed pulled like your
nails get pulled out from your nail bed
you'll torture yes waterboarded you
could get your teeth pulled out you'll
know you're ingesting like insects fake
vomit fake blood or actually vomit so
fake vomit and real vomit no I don't
know about that but it seems like they
make you swallow your own vomit and [ __ ]
like so fake real and your own vomit
yeah it could be either work or any
cocktail of on it JK party what so then
these are JK party things up the nail
bed honestly when I was reading this
[ __ ] I'm like I've been through some
[ __ ] with JK party yeah I can do this I
hate my own vomit and bugs baby people
Jake your party you called yourself not
a [ __ ] and you're like I ain't no [ __ ]
and then you ate the [ __ ] thing you
just threw up nobody asks you I don't
want to think about that so anyway so
the requirements here is that the
payment is just a bag of dog food cuz
this guy has five dogs so you don't
really need a pay other than just giving
dog food you must ears or older or 18 to
20 with parents of parents approval you
have to complete a sports physical and a
doctor's letter stating that you're
physically and mentally cleared you have
to pass a background check provided by
the place you must be screened via
Facebook FaceTime or phone you have to
have proof of medical insurance and you
have to sign a very detailed 40 page
waiver and you have to pass a portable
drug test on the day of the show this
this show can last up to 10 hours but
it's harder to get here and become a
police officer yeah yeah why is it worth
exactly so people I don't know why
people run marathons you people get a
thrill
same section people like I went through
torture and I survived let me explain a
little bit more so then like his
previous shows they were to show that he
calls him show or towards oh it was like
live taping him no he does Oh actually
records absolutely everything that these
looks like the song because he has he
says that he she specializes and like
hypnosis and stuff so people end up he
really gets into your head just like
excretion tea and so people think that
certain things happen to them when they
were there but because he's recording
everything he has to provide that oh it
didn't happen edited raw footage to the
authorities to show them like see I
didn't do this it's just I really [ __ ]
with their minds where they think I did
this I mean if he's like listen I got
five dogs I gotta be doing this [ __ ] so
then the previous one very clever
then this new wine is called desolation
he says that this one cuz he makes me
watch a two-hour movie of explaining
like like the first 30 minutes cuz I
watched that it was like just him
explaining like I don't like cussing so
every time you cut oh because he's
offering $20,000 to ever to whoever can
pass the entire thing Oh Shh he's like I
promise you don't even come for the
money because you will not get a penny
from me I promise you you won't
so he's like pretty much the whole time
is like explaining that so every time
you cut he'll remove five hundred bucks
or whatever it is people go [ __ ] and the
other good chunk like an hour and a half
of the movie it's just a whole bunch of
testimonials of people who've tried to
do the manner and got like spit out like
they're just like we can't [ __ ] do
this if any Navy SEALs watching this you
want 20 grand no so he's saying that
maybe feels like Green Berets like all
these people like the top-tier military
people they can't even do it you know
what you know why yeah it's because they
have a they're going to the wrong people
you need to get crackheads assemble a
team of crack
no no no by minute I'm gonna get him so
logical test but I'm gonna yeah yeah no
no don't kill that yeah and and so now
there's this petition online I'll get
five packets seventy five thousand
signatures to shut down McCamey Manor
because they are claiming that is just a
tortured tortured chamber under disguise
and that they do screaming's just to
find the weakest most easily manipulated
people to do the haunt but they're
volunteering though yeah so then that's
the thing like there's a ton of people
are like they're [ __ ] volunteering
like it's a consent
it's a consensual torture or whatever it
is but then these people are trying to
shut it down they're just like who's
these people the people that lost I
don't know just anyone who can like you
know they they are purposely trying to
find the weak people to get like so he
could get it kicked out of this he also
has to notify the cops before he starts
to show and lets them know like hey
don't come guns a-blazing like you have
in the past because these people have
signed sign [ __ ] they want us to torture
them because they're literally screaming
and then the other thing too is that he
original leader like at one point you
could at any time that's the thing i was
trying to get to so at one point they
didn't allow for safe or something but
now they do because they were they were
like the [ __ ] even like BDSM torture
that has safe words yeah so now they're
saying or he the manor is claiming that
you can use a safe word and there is
like two things i think that you can say
like these things i will not let you do
to me like I absolutely refuse to do
those thing with my nails in my teeth so
he says no I know like oh but he's
saying that this one is not physical at
all it's all mental oh that's even worse
you show is the desolation one it's all
mental like you won't even get touched
but it's pretty much to mine [ __ ] you
into thinking you're completely alone
and like really crushed your mental do
you want to do this me no I'm just like
I thought you wanted to get kidnapped -
no that's all [ __ ] no I don't want to do
this I kind of want to
what that let me show you go to the
trailer let me show you mine Lord and
then if I get out love extreme you spend
hours watching the footage and then like
editing a so he's like he's passionate
yeah super
these are the past 100 Vivian mud ten
hours people ten hours all right they
showed up drill on their backs people
are well aware of what they're doing
Wow
what is that mouth this is [ __ ] crazy
that guy was drowning in a cage now
that's kind of fun right there though
yeah I know
[Music]
why is that guys smiling did he just
finish it yeah he just he quit no one's
ever finished it like he just handed up
quitting and then he films everyone
saying like you don't want to do this
yeah cuz they push it all over you but
it just seems [ __ ] wild can he even
lost his own [ __ ] I don't think so but
he says like he personalizes each show
depending on like the person oh if you
tell them like Oh big aspheres
or snakes then my biggest candy no don't
do it that's easy
[ __ ] hey hey Care Bears man I'm
[ __ ] freaked out my Care Bear that's
where the questionnaire comes into play
yeah you know what 64 thousand and five
people have signed the change.org
petition to shut it down because they're
saying like you know these people some
of the people that have done this
already they need to seek professional
psychiatric no [ __ ] we could have all
told you that we're gonna have for sure
listen this is like when people who
don't watch people want them banned from
stages and stuff and it's like they're
not even the fanbase yeah so people just
[ __ ] interjecting themselves [ __ ]
them yeah really crazy accusations here
too because they're saying that he uses
needles to inject people with drugs
which forces them to have hallucinations
and that he hires people that have
violent histories and and sex offenders
so like even his his volunteer employees
aren't even like safe people I mean but
what if they're passionate about torture
and they get to do this in an express it
in a legal way thank you they're saying
that people that have done these tours
like some people like the people I end
up working there's because they tried it
and they say how can I join to hurt
people - yeah it's just like it's
consensual it's like ah yeah to me if
it's consensual yeah you want to give
yourself PTSD you
good for you it's better that they
express themselves this way then they
[ __ ] kidnap a kid and do that [ __ ]
yeah but then the people are trying to
shut it down they're like well maybe he
already did it and now he's doing this
to cover up his well you guys need to be
detected you need to you need to be
detectives and do your actual detective
work and get evidence you [ __ ]
imaginary hos like David people give a
[ __ ] about [ __ ] they shouldn't [ __ ]
give a [ __ ] about
[Music]